Hi, I want to make this message short and sweet.
It's aimed at those of you who might be considering some new year's resolutions
motivated by the hope that 2021 could be better than 2020 a low
bar. I would say considering the nature of the last year,
some years ago, my colleagues, Dr. Robert peel and Dr. Daniel Higgins,
and I developed a suite of four psychotherapeutic writing programs available
at self-authoring dot com designed to help people clarify their
past, understand their present personality and improve their future.
These are available. As I said, itself, offering.com.
The future offering program,
one of the four is particularly appropriate for the new years.
Personality renewal that resolutions are designed to bring about it helps
guide its users through the process of thinking about their intimate
relationships, career plans, or lack thereof, educational goals,
social engagement,
optimization of mental and physical health and productive,
meaningful use of personal or private time.
Our research described at the self-authoring site indicates that university and
college students who used this program to organize their visions and dreams for
the future were much more likely to remain in their programs of study and more
likely to be successful while doing so. The program appears to work.
If you want some help with your resolutions consider using it,
you can find the future authoring program on the self-authoring com website
under products because it's new years.
We hope that many people might be inclined to taking some positive steps forward
and we've set up a 50% discount coupon code on the program,
bringing it surprise to about seven 50 us.
The coupon code is F a 2021 that's FAA
2021. If you want to use it, go to self-authoring dot com.
The URL is in the video description under products, select future offering,
click buy now,
and then enter F a that's future offering FAA 2021 in the
coupon code box on the purchase future offering page.
We sincerely hope that the program is useful and that the discount is welcome.
Happy new year.